لقد كنت رائعًا بشأن أشياء أخرى
مثل التسريب بالتأكيد أمر مهم ،
لقد تحدثت عن الطريقة التي
تشاهد بها لعبة Game of Thrones ليس مرة واحدة ولكن مرتين
يستغرق ذلك بعض الوقت ولكن أيضًا عن
أهمية أنشطة هواية
وأنشطة منتظمة أخبرنا ما هو
الفرق  الذي أحدثه لك وما هو
الاختلاف الذي يمكن أن يحدث للأشخاص
الذين يمرون بهذا الآن جيدًا
أولاً وقبل كل شيء ، ذكرت الجدول
الزمني واعتقدت أن
الجدول الزمني المتوازن مهم عليك أن
تعتني بنفسك تحتاج إلى القيام
بعملك  إذا كنت قادرًا على القيام بذلك ، فأنت بحاجة
إلى قضاء بعض الوقت في الاهتمام
ببيئتك عندما كنت في الفضاء ،
المحطة الفضائية هنا ستكون
شقتك في منزلك ، ولكنك تحتاج أيضًا
إلى هذا النوع من المنافذ التي تعرف
أشياء يمكنك القيام بها  القيام بذلك هو أمر
ترفيهي ينفصل
عنك ، تعرف أن ما يحدث يفصل
نفسك عن الأخبار في حالتي على
المحطة الفضائية لقد حاولت أن أكتب
لأشخاص آخرين تعرفهم يعزفون موسيقى يفعلها الناس
كل هذه الأشياء مهمة جدًا
للصحة العقلية وأنت تعلم أن صحتنا العقلية
مهمة جدًا
لصحتنا الجسدية ، نعم ، لقد فعلت ذلك في
الأسبوع الماضي مع أطفالي ، كنا نقوم
بأشياء مثل وظائف تنظيف
منضدة الأدوات التي تعرف أشياء  من هذا القبيل ، ولكن
حتى لعب كرة القدم كما تعلم
بالخارج ، يساعدني ذلك في تذكر مشاهدة
مقاطع لك وأنت تتسكع مع ابنتك
من الفضاء ، تخبرنا عن
أهمية هذا النوع من الاتصال ، أعتقد أنني
أشعر أن التكبير هو أحد أبطال
حق التباعد الاجتماعي  هذا صحيح لأن
الناس يجتمعون معًا ولكن
تقريبًا من
المهم جدًا البقاء على اتصال جيد جدًا ،
كان لدينا بريد إلكتروني كان لدينا هاتف لدينا القدرة
على معرفة
مكالمات مؤتمرات الفيديو المحدودة وأعتقد في هذه
البيئة أنك تعرف زوجتي و  لقد
تواصلنا في الليالي القليلة الماضية مع بعض
الأصدقاء الذين لم نرهم منذ وقت طويل
، وأعتقد أنك تعرف ما إذا كان الناس يستخدمون
التكنولوجيا فور خروجهم من هذا
الأمر ، فسيجدون  أنهم يعرفون أنهم يقوون
علاقاتهم مع
أفراد عائلاتهم على الرغم من أنهم لا يستطيعون
رؤيتهم صداقة متجددة جسديًا ، لذا
فأنت تعرف في أي شيء سيء
وصعب إذا نظرت بجدية كافية
أعتقد أنه يمكنك دائمًا العثور على بعض الأشياء الجيدة فيه